Mói chừng Irán ông á bắt sát rock chí ngày 1 thống bài trên bố,
Tây Rán sẽ chì cho lại bản đàn phản về Mỹ,
nếu nhận được cảm kết chắc tránh rằng Washington sẽ không tiếp tục phát động
có cuộc tận công cô dự trong quá trình thường lợp.
Ông khẳng định Irán cần thiên thời gian để đường ra khuy định về việc nỗ lệ làm phán.
Đông thời gian mạnh cạnh cửng ngoại ra về Mỹ sẽ không bao giờ đảo lám hoặc toàn.
Mói chừng Irán chỉ cũng khẳng định Irán đã chứng mấy năng lực tự vẻ trong cuộc dục
và sẽ tục bảo vệ đất nước, nếu bị tấn công,
ông nhân mạnh chú trình hạt nhân hoặc về đại trở thành nghiệm từ hào của Irán,
công thế bị phá huy chỉ bảo vòng đặt và nếu cần tư hơi Rán có thể nhắn trong các cuộc tổn thích để tục phát triển.
Chứ đó, tổn thống Mỹ ở đường năng trăm cho biết Mỹ và Irán sẽ thiên hành đạm phán về chú trình hạt nhân trong tổn tự
với nỗ dụng chính xoài quan trịp Irán lương lần rộng Rán Nhung,
để đồ lệ việc Washington nơi lòng các bạn pháp trứng phát.
Nó phai viên Mỹ, phát triển hạt nhân hoặc đất nước kiến sẽ tham vận với đại dễ Irán,
trong những ngày tới, tuy nhiên, trình quyền Irán, giữa đường thẳng định sẽ không tự bảo quyền phát triển cho chính hạt nhân hoặc
bình.
Các vòng tham vấn chức nơi đã bị giản đoạn, gió trên dứt quân sự của Israel,
cùng có lợt không kết của Mỹ nhằm vào cơ sở hạt nhân Irán khiến chuyển vòng đặt phán sớm trở lại, trở nên khó đoán.